hey schön dass ihr dabei seid zdf heute
live während in der ukraine weiter
heftig gekämpft wird versuchen
ermittlerinnen un-ermittler parallel
bereits jetzt beweise zu sichern die
menschenrechtsverletzungen zu
dokumentieren das leid das den menschen
angetan wurde das sind aktuelle bilder
aus wut scham immer noch werden hier
leichen geborgen nach ukrainischen
angaben sind in dem vorort von kiew mehr
als 400 tote gefunden worden viele
schicksale sind noch gänzlich ungeklärt
und vor der stadtverwaltung stehen die
menschen schlange und hoffen dass es
nachrichten gibt über ihre angehörigen
die immer noch vermisst sind
aber auch die andere seite wird von den
ermittlerinnen und ermittlern untersucht
wie die ukraine mit russischen
kriegsgefangenen umgeht der chefankläger
des internationalen
strafgerichtshofs der ist vor ort in der
ukraine und sagt die ukraine ist jetzt
ein tatort deshalb geht es heute bei uns
um folgendes thema kriegsverbrechen in
der ukraine
so versuchen ermittler beweise zu
sichern und eure fragen und kommentare
dazu könnt ihr gerne stellen per mail
oder direkt im stream und im chat ich
habe da immer ein auge drauf und wir
können diese fragen stellen an unsere
experten und einen experten den wir
später noch in der sendung haben denn
wir können jetzt zuerst sprechen mit
bergers villa sie ist live in der
ukraine ist als ermittlerin für human
rights watch dort schönen guten abend
frau wille
guten abend
frau wille sie suchen nach diesen
beweisen für menschenrechtsverletzungen
also sammeln die wirklich all das was in
den letzten wochen passiert ist und was
haben sie da erlebt in diesen letzten
tagen als sie unterwegs war
die organisation human rights watch ist
jetzt schon seit der invasion in der
ukraine
ich selbst war schon am anfang drei der
erst drei wochen des konflikts hier ich
bin da wieder zurück gereist bin vor ein
paar tagen wieder zurückgekehrt in die
ukraine und seit anfang des konfliktes
haben wir eine ganze reihe von
menschenrechtsverletzungen dokumentieren
das kriegsrecht verletzt wo also sie
belasten geschädigt wurden und es gab
auch absichtlicher angriff auf die
zivilbevölkerung wir haben eingesehen
dass
russische truppen
streubomben benutzt haben und auch
landminen und andere sehr gefährliche
waffen und um bücher weise haben wir
auch andere verletzung gesehen wie zum
beispiel
tötung an exekutionen von zivilisten
oder kriegsgefangenen und es gibt auch
anschuldigungen von sexueller gewalt
wir sprechen gleich darüber wie sie dort
genau vorgehen um also dieses leid zu
dokumentieren und auch was es braucht um
einen beweis quasi zu finden aber wir
wollen erstmal schauen noch gemeinsam
auf einen ort der in der letzten zeit in
den letzten wochen besonders in der
öffentlichkeit stand butscher nachdem
die russischen soldaten die stadt
verlassen haben nach wochenlanger
belagerung haben wir dort unfassbare
bilder gesehen leichen auf der straße
menschen tot neben ihren fahrrädern und
tim kröger war für uns vor ort in butter
aufräumen in butter ob mit schwerem
gerät oder dem besen den menschen kann
es nicht schnell genug gehen die äußeren
zeichen der russischen angriffe der
besatzung zu beseitigen innerlich aber
bleiben die wunden valentina weil sie
lieber hat alles miterlebt die angriffe
die toten auf der straße sie nennt uns
namen zeigt wo die menschen erschossen
lagen und beerdigt worden
ich weine die ganze zeit ich weine nur
das ist alles weinen was soll ich nur
fühlen nach all dem es war doch so schön
hier
ob die wunden irgendwann heilen wird
auch von der aufarbeitung der
gräueltaten abhängen mord folter
vergewaltigung bomben auf zivilisten die
ermittlungen laufen bereits massengräber
werden geöffnet hunderte todesopfer aus
dem großraum kiel obduziert
jede leiche die bereits identifiziert
ist wird forensisch untersucht wie jene
die noch nicht identifiziert sind werden
wir dna tests durchführen um
herauszufinden wer sie sind dann werden
wir die todesursache
feststellen
und jeden tag werden weitere leichen
entdeckt
pressetermin mit der ukrainischen
generalstaatsanwälten in butter es geht
um tausende fälle mutmaßlicher
kriegsverbrechen mit hunderten
verdächtigen auf seiten des russischen
militärs und der russischen führung
wir sollten unsere fälle so aufbereiten
dass die ankläger der internationalen
gerichte unsere felle aufnehmen und
unsere beweise nutzen können nach den
standards internationalen humanitären
rechts
habe es gerade gehört es geht darum
beweise so zu präsentieren dass sie
nutzbar sind die funktioniert das genau
wie gehen sie vor vor ort was zählt als
beweis
mal um zu verstehen
vorhanden ist müssen wir zeugen befragen
zeugen
und opfer des missbrauchs sind ganz ganz
wichtig wir werden verschiedene zeugen
und opfer interviewen wenn es zu stehen
beim ereignis kommt und wir wollen
verstehen was ist passiert damals gab es
ein militärisches ziel in der umgebung
bat das ein angriff der nur auf
zivilisten gerichtet da oder auch auf
militärische ziele ab wenn erst mal die
folgen aussagen haben und die wird
natürlich nach den ereignissen gesammelt
dann besuchen wir das bild zu komplett
zu komplettieren dessen was da geschehen
ist wir können das durch fotos und video
inhalte machen über die sozialen medien
manchmal ist es so dass die zeugen über
die fragen selber auch bilder gemacht
haben die sind sehr wertvoll
denn die metadaten auf diesen dateien
das sind auch intakt und dann wissen wir
ganz genau wann diese bilder aufgenommen
wurden und wo und dadurch können wir
dann sehen was da wirklich passiert ist
auf diesen bildern was wird wichtig
trotz leben und dann satellitendaten
satellitenbilder wir sind auch nützlich
das heißt wir bestellen der satelliten
gehört die uns zeigen gast damals am
boden passierte während diese
geschehnisse die von den leuten hier
beschrieben wurden die passierten und
zum schluss besuchen wir dann die orte
wo etwas passiert ist um selber auch uns
ein bild zu machen welche speicher
schaden dort eingerichteten zu
identifizieren wo die leichten sehen wo
sie gefunden wurden und im feld wie
butter und da gab es natürlich auch ganz
viele andere dörfer und städte außer als
papierform an ähnliche geschehnisse
gesehen hat
zahlen von leichen dafür suchen so
schnell wie möglich zu diesen orten zu
kommen
in den maßen das sicherste wollen die
beweise sind bevor sie weggebracht
werden oder bevor dinge verändert werden
haben das auch gerade gesehen in den
bildern die wir gezeigt haben in als sie
geantwortet haben also da sieht man auch
es werden tatsächlich also schon tote
menschen wieder aus den gräbern geholt
und obduziert und sie sagten sie haben
es angesprochen sie führen auch
interviews was haben ihnen die menschen
vor ort in diesen interviews erzählt und
berichtet von den letzten wochen
[Musik]
haben wir gut sich schlimme geschichten
mit gehört und wir machen auch mit
ersten menschen aus diesen gegenden auch
im nordwesten von 4
das macht mir schon während die
russischen truppen der gegen verhandelt
während die menschen in der besetzung
lebten wir haben als mit menschen
angefangen die läden ihren keller
versteckt war und die beschrieben wie
die gegend unter bombardements lagen lag
und jetzt geht die gleichen gegner
zurück und sehen wie diese gegner aus
sache aussieht und gestern haben wir
menschen gesprochen die uns darüber
berichtet habe in einem fall eine mutter
deren sohn
weggeschleppt wurde von russischen
truppen exekutiert sie später gleichere
sonst gesehen dass die russen gegangen
waren und bis dahin wussten gar nicht ob
da noch lebte oder schon tot war und vor
zwei wochen haben die rituellen
interviewt die in autos bahn versucht in
sicherheit zu fahren sie wurden von
russen beschossen und viele mitglieder
von deren gruppe die starben in diesem
land lockt wir haben die gegend selber
besichtigt wir haben die zerschossenen
autos gesehen damit vielen zeugen in
dieser vorfälle gesprochen und gestern
da waren wir an einem ort das war ein
ganz großes wohnhaus
und ist jetzt
hat man da noch nicht gegraben aber
schon wissen kann man davon ausgehen
dass 80 menschen tot sind und in den
kellern oder schutzräumen unter diesen
gebäuden liegen und die legen schon seit
dem ersten märz dort in diesen
schutzräumen und sind wahrscheinlich tot
und erst jetzt können die reste dieser
menschen von den sicherheitskräften
rausgeholt werden
sind erschütternde berichte die sie hier
für uns haben wir wollen euch kurz eine
karte zeigen die können wir uns
vielleicht auch hier gemeinsam auf dem
monitor angucken und zwar das recherche
kollektiv berlin kehrt hat hier ich gehe
mal ein bisschen mehr rein hat hier seit
beginn des krieges also zusammengetragen
informationen darüber wann immer
zivilisten wie sagt man dass zivile
gebiete zivile gebiete quasi getroffen
worden sind zivilisten verletzt worden
sind ihr seht es an diesen liedern
punkten kleine große es gibt also auch
gebiete da gibt es ganz viele eintragung
marie operativ kiew es gibt aber auch
eben kleinere gebiete wo also da
dokumentiert wurde ich versuche ich das
größer zu zeigen aber das wäre auch
etwas da könnt ihr alle zu hause mal
selbst rein schauen wenn ihr wollt wir
sehen also hier zahlreiche
dokumentationen unten ein zeitstrahl da
könnt ihr alle mal reinschauen
jetzt gibt es natürlich auch
herausforderungen für sie in dieser
beweissicherung das ist nicht ganz
einfach können sie uns darüber ein
bisschen berichten was für sie das
schwierige vor ort ist wenn sie
versuchen also beweise zu sammeln
also wie ihr bricht auch schon zeit ist
so dass viele familien die jetzt wieder
zurückgehen können die gegen den
politiker schlimmen ereignisse passieren
das was sie jetzt machen wollen ist
natürlich dass sie ihre geliebten finden
wollen ihre anverwandten und die wollen
die beerdigung und wie sie auch
berichtet haben das sind ja tatort und
die müssen als tatorte auch behandelt
werden das heißt wir brauchen zeit
den ermittlern den chance zu geben er
tatsächlich dorthin zu gehen die gar
nicht den ganzen tatort zu untersuchen
bevor die toten dann die gerichtsmedizin
gebracht können wo der
grund die tus ursache herausgefunden
werden kann bevor man dann die leichen
beerdigt eine andere herausforderung die
es fast positiv und das ist einzigartig
hier alt ist ein krieg der ukraine ich
habe das bei human rights watch noch nie
irgendwo in einem kriegsfall gesehen da
gibt es so viele rechtliche
möglichkeiten für die ermittlungen da
gibt es den internationalen gerichtshof
der tat gerichtshof da wird einem
durchgeführt sie haben den die chefs
staatsanwältin der ukraine und dann gibt
es noch andere länder zehn weitere
länder die staatsanwaltschaften haben
die sich mögliche kriegsverbrechen
diesen konflikt anschauen und das sind
wir natürlich die vorteile es gibt so
viele möglichkeiten den herauszufinden
aber es gibt auch potenziell
herausforderungen aufgrund der
kommunikation wegen dieser verschiedenen
staatsanwaltschaften die involviert sind
und es ist einfach ganz wichtig dass es
eine gute kommunikation und koordination
geht zwischen diesen verschiedenen
gruppen so dass die beweise richtig
gesichert werden sodass die
verschiedenen staatsanwaltschaften auch
die entsprechenden schlussfolgerungen
und beweise dort bekommen können
zum schluss noch die frage was ist das
bisherige fazit ihres bericht von human
rights watch
also es gibt verschiedene dinge die wir
besuchen in unserer arbeit
zum einen wollen wir natürlich diese
verschiedenen ermittlungen unterstützen
und steuern wir sind dort vor ort wir
sammeln die zeugenaussagen von opfern
und zeugen
und wir bringen das zusammen mit unseren
eigenen ermittlungen vor ort und das
kann praktisch den teams von inter das
jahr strafgerichtshof helfen auch
anderen teams die können dann nach
ausbilder bereiche die sich
konzentrieren wollen und dann gibt es
auch noch für andere anstrengungen in
unserer arbeit wir wollen die
verbrechen dokumentieren die besonders
auch aber nicht nur von den russischen
truppen aus durchgeführt wurden es ist
richtig dass die welt in echtzeit was da
passiert ist an verbrechen denn die
rechtliche aufarbeitung dort
wahrscheinlich jahre und wir müssen in
echtzeit diese informationen in die welt
streuen um zu zeigen wie dieser krieg
für die zivilisten vor ort aussieht und
eine priorität ist es für uns sicher zu
stellen dass unsere dokumentation auch
die menschen in russland erreicht denn
es ist ja die die öffentlichkeit in
russland und die öffentliche meinung und
russland je eine ausgegraben werden
möglicherweise auf die veränderung des
verhaltens der russisch strom
sicherzustellen dass die russischen
truppen sich mit internationalen recht
konform verhalten
das ist wichtig
danke an sie am berg es würde die als
ermittlerin für human rights watch
gerade in der ukraine ist vielen dank
für ihre antworten heute abend
und all diese beweise werden am ende
zählen um natürlich verantwortliche zu
gericht zu bekommen und das wird nicht
einfach werden und wie das genau
funktioniert und worauf es ankommt das
hat sarah tacke für uns zusammengefasst
vergewaltigung folter tötung von
zivilisten sind schwerste straftaten
auch im krieg
und diese mutmaßlichen kriegsverbrechen
in der ukraine können auch bei uns in
deutschland angeklagt werden hier in
karlsruhe ermittelt bereits der
generalbundesanwalt wer sich wie im
ukraine krieg schuldig gemacht hat
normalerweise wäre das deutsche
strafrecht für einen mord den ein russe
an eine ukrainerin in der ukraine
beginnt nicht zuständig wenn das aber
ein kriegsverbrechen sein sollte dann ja
dann ist deutschland zuständig
unabhängig davon wer die tat begeht und
wo sie begangen wird für diese
mutmaßlichen kriegsverbrechen in der
ukraine können in deutschland aber nur
putins kämpfer sicher bestraft werden er
selbst wohl nicht denn solange russlands
präsident putin im amt ist genießt er
nach völkerrechtlichen grundsätzen in
deutschland immunität und das schützt
ihn aktuell davor in deutschland
angeklagt zu werden anders hier am
internationalen strafgerichtshof in den
haag kann putin für kriegsverbrechen der
prozess gemacht werden
das römische statut erlaubt es bei
kriegsverbrechen verbrechen gegen die
menschlichkeit auch staatsoberhäupter
und auch solche von nicht
vertragsstaaten wie der russischen
föderation vor gericht zu stellen die
wesentliche herausforderung in diesem
zusammenhang sind eben wieder die
praktischen fragen es ist im moment
nicht wahrscheinlich dass putin so lange
im amt ist nach den haag kommen wird
denn hier hin wird russland ihn nicht
ausliefern und der internationale
strafgerichtshof kann selber keine
kriegsverbrecher festnehmen solange also
weder putin noch seine kämpfer gefasst
und ausgeliefert werden kann ihnen hier
nicht der prozess gemacht werden
wir können über völkerrechtliche fragen
jetzt insbesondere sprechen mit
professor markus haas soll er lehrt
völkerrecht an der uni genf ist einer
von drei experten der im auftrag der us
ze der internationalen organisation für
sicherheit und zusammenarbeit in europa
die menschenrechtslage im krieg gegen
die ukraine untersucht hat in den
letzten wochen schönen guten abend
esther soll nie
er soll die in ihrem bericht der gestern
veröffentlicht wurde sprechen sie von
einem muster das eine reihe von
verletzungen der menschenrechte und des
völkerrechts zeigt bei dem wort
kriegsverbrechen sind sie allerdings
nicht so klar und deutlich was ist die
unterscheidung da genau
ja also verletzungen des humanitären
völkerrechts und der menschenrechte
werden von statten gegangen oder von
bewaffneten gruppen internen konflikt
werden kriegsverbrechen von individuen
also streng rechtlich kann man nur von
einem kriegsverbrechen sprechen wenn man
weiß wie man das vorwirft und das muss
jemand individuelles seien natürlich
gibt es auch die verantwortung des
kommandanten aber da ist er nicht oder
sie
strafrechtlich verantwortlich bloß weil
sie die chefin war sondern
die person musste entweder den befehl
gegeben haben oder
wissen das verbrechen begangen werden
unter ihrem kommando und keine maßnahmen
dagegen ergreifen es ist also viel
schwieriger
kriegsverbrechen nachzuweisen als
verletzungen des humanitären
völkerrechts und in der tat in unserem
bericht
kommen wir zu vielen fragen zum schluss
dass da das humanitäre völkerrecht
verletzt wurde und jetzt geht es darum
dass man
feststellt werden das genau gemacht hat
der us präsident joe biden nannte die
russischen an den russischen
angriffskrieg gar einen völkermord warum
ist auch so was so schwer das so genau
präzise festzustellen und zu länger am
ende
also der begriff des völkermordes
erscheint mir doch übertrieben in diesem
zusammenhang der angriffskrieg das ist
unbestritten aber das ist nicht die
verantwortung jedes soldaten der damit
macht sondern das ist die verantwortung
des chefs also in unserem zusammenhang
eindeutig des russischen präsidenten
putin während wenn es einen krieg gibt
auch ein angriffskrieg dann müssen sich
beide parteien an das humanitäre
völkerrecht halten und beide parteien
können es auch verletzten und die
müssten sich an die gleichen regeln
halten das ist natürlich für die
öffentlichkeit und insbesondere vor der
ukrainerin und wo keiner schwierig zu
verstehen weil die sich sagen ja wenn
wir nur und häuser verteidigen
dann
können die uns doch nicht angreifen
natürlich darf russland die ukraine
nicht angreifen aber wenn die
ukrainischen truppen gewisse gebäude
verteidigen dann ist das keine
verletzung des humanitären folgen die
russischen truppen diese gebäude
angreifen und zerstören
es gibt schon viele fragen auch bei uns
im stream denn das ist ja alles gar
nicht so einfach beispielsweise wird
hier von marco bei youtube gefragt wie
lange dauert es bis der verantwortliche
und darüber müssen wir vielleicht auch
noch mal reden für kriegsverbrechen vor
gericht muss zunächst
wird sich ein bisschen deprimierend sei
nämlich die meisten kriegshaber kommen
im ehemaligen jugoslawien einige
jemen gaza
äthiopien kein einziger hier gibt es
doch jetzt hoffnung weil wie frau willi
das gesagt hat sich die internationale
gemeinschaft wirklich mobilisieren und
dann auch dann kann es natürlich lange
dauern wir hoffen nicht dass es so lange
dauert wie im krieg zwischen georgien
und russland wo ja der internationale
strafgerichtshof auch
zuständig war und ermittelt und der
krieg fand 2008 statt und vor zwei
wochen wurde die erste person angeklagt
ja das ist viele viele jahre später also
es dauert sehr lange das nehme ich mir
gute jungs verbrechen verlieren ja nicht
und nicht mal mehr das weiß man ja wohl
wenn nazi verbrechen darum gibt es heute
noch nach 40 50 jahren verfolgt und das
ist natürlich symbolisch auch wichtig
dass die leute die solche verbrechen
begehen wissen dass überall auf der welt
das ist ja der welt rechtsgrundsatz den
sie erklärt haben dass sie dran kommen
können auch viel später wenn vielleicht
aus regime ändert und
lassen sie uns vielleicht noch mal
gemeinsam oft bilderschauen bilder die
auch eben das grauen für uns so weit weg
hier ja real machen und uns auch eine
vorstellung von diesem eigentlich
unvorstellbaren geben und zwar bilder
aus mariupol wo eine geburtsklinik
angegriffen wurde wo schwangere und
babys die bei diesen bildern die wir
gerade sehen im hintergrund die dort
eben waren schwangere und babys in der
folge starben also hier wurde eine
geburtsklinik angegriffen außerdem wurde
in mariupol das theater im stadtzentrum
angegriffen hier sehen wir meine ich
noch die geburtsklinik gleich sehen wir
also das theater im stadtzentrum das
angegriffen wurde obwohl sich dort rund
1000 menschen aufgehalten haben sollen
die dort also schutz gesucht haben das
sind natürlich bilder die uns hier
tagtäglich erreichen wir sehen sie uns
gerade gemeinsam an auch das haben sie
untersucht die ereignisse in mariupol in
ihrem bericht was war hier für sie das
ergebnis
weil
russland dazu eine erklärung hatte und
wir nachweisen konnten dass dieser
erklärung zeigt
einerseits beim bei der geburtsklinik
behauptete russland das die
geburtsklinik gar nicht mehr hat solche
benutzt wurde sondern vom ukrainischen
proben besetzt war und das versucht sie
zu belegen mit fotos aber da konnte man
nachweisen dass diese fotos mindestens
einen kilometer von der geburtsklinik
entfernt
aufgenommen wurden und diese leute die
angeblich auf dem dach der klinik waren
also in wirklichkeit ein kilometer weit
entfernt war und
zu den theater war es auch nicht
schwierig war russland behauptet die
lokale haben das selber in die luft
gejagt und das ist erstens also doch
sehr wahrscheinlich aber zweitens der
krater neben dem theater den glaube ich
habe hier haben sie gezeigt am anfang
der ist nach experten
von einem luftangriff und die ukraine
gravierenden nicht ihre eigene orte an
und nicht von einer wie die großen
behauptet haben von einer bombe die
dargelegt wurde
herstammen das waren also eigentlich
einfache fälle meistens ist es aber viel
komplizierter sie haben einfach ein
ziviles haus das zerstört wurde und das
beweist eben noch nicht dass humanitäres
völkerrecht verletzt wurde denn
vielleicht wurde dieses haus von
demokratischen gruppen verteidigt
vielleicht war dort eine kommandostelle
vielleicht haben sich
haben sich die russen falsch haben die
falsch geschossen die darf ich sie daran
erinnern dass sms app spital in kundus
von den amerikanern aber
da kommt wieder unsere argumentation
unsere was uns hilft ist wenn jetzt die
amerikaner 30 spezieller in
afghanistan zerstört hätten dann würde
man an den irrtum nicht mehr glauben und
so argumentieren wir dass diese vielen
zerstörung
können keine erklärung haben dass es in
jedem fall auch dort wo es weit von der
sogenannten
frontlinie entfernt war weil er auf der
frontlinie könnte hier das haus an
militärische ziel sein wenn es
verteidigt werden warum aber irgendwie
in kiew inaktiv sind doch sehr viele
gebäude zerstört worden und die können
ja nicht alle militärische ziele gewesen
sein und selbst wenn sie es gewesen
wären wären diese angriffe mitten in
diesen gebieten unverhältnismäßig
und die russen haben waffen benutzt wie
diese streubomben die nicht verboten
sind für staaten die nicht bei der audio
konvention dabei sind aber es gibt eine
verpflichtung im moment eher im
völkerrecht bei der auswahl der mitte
mit dem man auch ein militärisches
zipper angreift
möglichst ein mittel zu benutzen dass
die zivilbevölkerung am wenigsten in
gefahr bringt und das ist eindeutig dass
die russischen truppen auch andere
mittel hatten als nur diese streuber
wählen sie ein ziel mitten in einer
stadt angelaufen es gibt inzwischen
einige fragen bei uns im stream und vor
allem auch ein bisschen unverständnis
oder zumindest nachfragen warum ist am
ende also wirklich so schwer ist
jemanden zu belangen da möchte zum
beispiel class of me bei youtube wissen
warum ändert man das völkerrecht nicht
das ist doch ein unding denn
kriegsverbrecher nie zur rechenschaft
gebracht werden können er bezieht sich
damit auf ihre aussage dass das
tatsächlich ja sehr selten nur passiert
ja gut das ist wie bei allen verbrechen
glaube ich es ist doch wichtig dass die
staatsanwaltschaft jenseits jeden
vernünftigen zweifel nachweisen muss
dass der das war wir hatten zum beispiel
in der schweiz im fall eines serbischen
kriegsverbrechern in den balkankriegen
der wurde dann freigesprochen nicht weil
die zeugen nicht gewaltig wurden aber
weil es nichts fest stand dass er das
wirklich wahr sie konnten ihn nicht
genügend identifizieren ich wiederhole
das problem bei kriegsverbrechen ist sie
müssen nachweisen dass eine gewisse
person war oder der kommandant und ich
würde jetzt das volk reicht nicht so
ändern dass ich sage sozusagen
jeder soldat der in einem krieg
teilnimmt weil eben kriegsverbrechen
begangen werden ist ein kriegsverbrecher
dann wäre nämlich auch die israelischen
und die
amerikanischen und die saudischen die
äthiopischen soldaten alle
kriegsverbrecher also höre ich sagen
behaupten wir nicht alle zwischen
soldaten und kriegsverbrecher wir müssen
das einzelnen leuten nachweis ich würde
etwas vergleicht also nicht ändern noch
schwieriger macht das das ganze
natürlich dass es in einem krieg auch
immer zwei seiten gibt in diesem krieg
auch es gibt auch häufig die russische
seite die die ukraine beschuldigt auch
verbrechen zu gehen wir zeigen jetzt nur
einen kleinen ausschnitt eines videos
denn der anfang sehr brutal das wurde
gedreht bei kiew ist zeigt offenbar die
ukrainische soldaten auf mehrere
russische gefangene schießen was hat ihr
bericht hier ergeben über natürlich auch
die anschuldigung der anderen seite der
russischen seite
bericht stellt fest dass beide seiten um
an den tieren völkerrecht verletzt haben
aber die verletzung
russlands
häufiger sind und schwer wie und in der
tat sie haben recht kriegsgefangene ist
ein problem der ukraine
in dem sinne dass die ukraine mal was
man menschlich verstehen aber nicht
entschuldigen kann einfach davon
ausgehen jeder
soldat ist ein verbrecher und
damit wurden die in gefängnisse gesteckt
während kriegsgefangenen müssen
kriegsgefangenenlager
interniert werden und das internationale
komitee vom morgen kreuz das nach dem
dritten abkommen die besuchen muss
können da kann die bis heute nicht
besuchen übrigens auch auf russischer
seite dicht und was mir persönlich
sorgen macht ist dass die zahlen der
kriegsgefangenen relativ gering sind
verglichen mit den zahlen der tod und da
gibt es gewisse erfahrungs zahlen aus
anderen kriegen und das
lässt ein befürchten aber dafür haben
wir keinerlei beweis außer dieser
plausibilität überlegung dass vielleicht
gewisse
soldaten die sich ergeben erschossen
werden was ein kriegsverbrechen wäre
oder dass sie im geheimen gefangen
gehalten wird
der gerichtshof in den haag der wäre
dann der natürlich am ende der
untersucht und verfolgt diese
kriegsverbrechen verbrechen gegen die
menschlichkeit und den völkermord der
chefankläger des internationalen
gerichtshofs karin k der war selbst im
buch und sagte wenn es verbrechen gibt
müssen richter entscheiden ob
haftbefehle oder vorladung ausgestellt
werden bei uns im stream gibt es jetzt
aber schon auch noch mal ganz
grundsätzliche fragen zum beispiel von
atomar ist er dazu zunächst mal fragt
wie stehen die chancen dass putin
überhaupt angeklagt wird
dazu müsste man nachweisen so wie man
das bei den nazi-verbrechen tun konnte
weil die alles dokumentiert haben dass
die entweder befehle gegeben dass sie
putin befehle gegeben haben jetzt fangt
an frauen sogar vergewaltigung das kann
ich mir fast nicht vorstellen oder dass
er eben die gewissen information eine
art und wie diese diktaturen nehmer sind
die umgeben sich von leuten die ihnen
diese informationen im nicht geben also
ist es schwierig im einzelnen so etwas
nachweisen aber ich glaube wir sollten
uns auch nicht so auf putin
konzentrieren sondern auf die ganze
magie der
obwohl sie streitkräfte und da ist das
hauptproblem einfach im moment kann man
der
angeklagten nicht habhaft werden und
meines erachtens zu recht kann niemand
in abwesenheit verurteilt werden im
gerade hatten wir auch noch mal dass
nutzer erklärung die bilder gesehen vom
chefankläger des internationalen
gerichtshofs als sie uns die antwort
gegeben haben es gibt noch eine weitere
frage und zwar droht eigentlich keine
generelle dürfte
weil das das ist glaube ich wichtig
natürlich ist der internationale
strafgerichtshof wichtig aber es ist
auch wichtig dass alle starten und da an
herrn deutschland vorbildlich gehandelt
handeln aber auch dass die ukraine und
russland
strafverfolgung auf dem die eu keiner
hat sehr viele
strafverfahren eingeleitet leider nur
strafverfahren gegen russen kein
einziges gegen ukraine und die wussten
die haben auch strafe verhaftet aber
dagegen nur keine nicht gegen russen und
das ist bedauerlich denn es wäre
natürlich viel einfacher wenn der staat
selbst sich um die fälle kümmert in den
seine eigenen truppen das wird er
erfolgreich verletzt haben
zwei ganz kurze fragen noch
zusammengefasst zum schluss zum einen
möchte seeland 1 gerne wissen wie
schnell kann man mit einem ergebnis
rechnen zu kriegsverbrechen oder
verletzung des völkerrechts und dann
noch eine weitere frage klar auf meedia
fragt droht eigentlich keine generelle
strafen keine generelle strafe für den
start eines angriffskriegs also einmal
die frage wie schnell kann es gehen und
die andere gibt es eine generelle strafe
für start eines angriffskriegs
ja also wie lange er
war ein erstes ergebnis zum beispiel
unser bericht ist schon ein ergebnis das
er gestern den staaten präsentiert haben
und
da mir beispielsweise festgestellt dass
gewisse russe überhaupt dohmen dass es
in wirklichkeit die ukraine sind die die
handeln für machen auf ihre eigenen
leute einfach nicht stimmen und das ist
doch wichtig
und andererseits
sollte ich glaube nicht wir sollten uns
rein auf
die verfolgung von kriegsverbrechern
konzentrieren sondern immer auch die
verantwortung von staaten und das führt
uns zur zweiten frage wo es natürlich
theoretisch so ist das jetzt russland
schadenersatz bezahlen und zwar für
sämtliche schäden offenbar eine region
bisher in der ukraine
und wir wissen ja aus der geschichte wie
das endete mit deutschland nach dem
ersten weltkrieg solche reparationen
aber ist was sehr wichtig ist ist die
wiedergutmachung in dem sinne daß
rußland eingesteht dass ein
angriffskrieg geführt hat und heute ist
noch russland in der welt unglaublich
isoliert also die staatengemeinschaft
die nimmt das nicht einfach so hin ich
würde sagen für das völkerrecht fahrers
eigentlich ein erfolg dass viele staaten
die eigentlich traditionellerweise sich
dann neutral verhalten sei denn die
schweiz hat ihre neutralität
zumindest soweit es über das ein
rechtlich jene ausgeht
praktisch verlassen und er hat gesagt
nein da können wir nicht neutral sein
sagt der völkerrechtler
markus us only vielen dank dass sie
heute abend bei uns zu gast waren das
war eine freude
es wäre schöner wenn wir weniger um
erfreuliche themen
da haben sie recht und damit entlasten
wir euch jetzt auch in den abend vielen
dank dass ihr bei uns zu gast war
und wir natürlich irgendwann hoffentlich
auch wieder über andere themen sprechen
können aber im moment sind das die
themen die unseren alltag alle
beschäftigen die uns beschäftigen im
alltag und deswegen danke dass ihr
fragen gestellt habt und seit gerne
wieder dabei bis dahin tschüss